rihanna does have a number of quite
lucrative endorsement partnerships the
likes of river island worth over a
million dollars eight hundred thousand
pounds there about puma for about a
million dollars as well you can see why
they might be up in arms about this
absolutely i mean the thing about brands
generally whether they're commercial
brands organization brands or whether
they're personal brands they are worth a
lot of money your brand is your most
important asset and they're going to be
a big fight over who owns and who's got
control of that brand so it's a really
interesting quite landmark case this
actually and i think it might get a few
retailers in particular worried indeed
and you can see exactly why celebrities
in particular this is big business isn't
it i mean these are just a few examples
of some of the deals uh that are going
on here the brand can be worth more than
their frankly their day jobs absolutely
well the thing about brand rather than
just being a marketing phenomenon or
just a famous personality is it generate
some long-term income for you so it
might be you're a talented footballer or
a tennis player whatever but it'll be
the endorsements it'll be the way that
you use the power of your image that
really is going to generate the big
bucks so again there's going to be a big
fight over that and that's why today has
been so interesting why beyonce will be
a fan of pepsi but yeah this is a really
interesting one isn't it kiss the band
only 200 000 of the last album sold but
gene simmons says that actually their
money comes through merchandising
basically absolutely and that's why you
need to think about brand first and
category second because it's the brand
that generates all of this merchandising
you know possibility but actually just
making records appearing here that
that's not what does it it's what you do
with it that counts maybe that's an
interesting story again attached to this
guy coffins and condoms apparently they
endorsed but let's go back to rihanna
here because of course for her it was
all about this t-shirt here five million
pounds you show up to topshop and we've
got another case as well richard pryor's
widow he's the comedian of course again
suing over a t-shirt
saying they own the image important
stuff
it is really important stuff and i think
what's important also is that of course
in english law we don't have the you
know image rights as such what they have
won the case although is passing off
which is actually if people think that
rihanna endorses that t-shirt that is
worth a lot of money and frankly
rihanna's got a bit of business going on
with a rival company with river island
so they weren't going to find it very
amusing that topshop were going to make
money out of this supposed passing off
so it is interesting and also her face
is a very important part of her visual
identity that again is the thing that's
going to generate a lot of money
absolutely thank you so much thank you